so there's this conjecture due to paul
erdesh one of the great mathematicians
of the 20th century he's uh like
everyone interested in the prime numbers
and posed a very uh beautiful conjecture
to do with primitive sets this
conjecture is now a full theorem why is
it a full theorem it's because of you
yeah yeah i i recently proved it all
right before we get into perimeter sets
i just wanted to start with a nice quote
of gauss that i always love mathematics
is the queen of the sciences and number
theory is the queen of mathematics let
me see if an analogy will hit with you
we have the queen here in england i
guess uh and her majesty has the crown
jewels right uh there are these
beautiful diamonds number theory is the
queen of mathematics then i would say
that the primes kind of are these kind
of precious diamonds these glistening
and beautiful objects if uh the queen
has a whole horde a whole hoard of crown
jewels like what would be the the full
collection of jewels in this analogy
with uh number theory and my proposal is
that this would be the class of
primitive sets
we say a set is primitive if it
satisfies a certain property and the
collection of all such sets are the
primitive sets but a good thing to keep
in mind is that for example with a prime
number that is a property of a number so
it a number is prime if it has no uh
factors uh other than one in itself so
this is a property about numbers and by
contrast primitive sets are properties
about sets or properties about
collections of numbers so it has less to
do with an individual number but rather
kind of the whole family and so this is
maybe where this uh analogy is coming in
of looking at like the whole uh
hoard of crown jewels so all the even
numbers are set uh yes the set of even
numbers odd numbers numbers that have no
sevens in them the squares the cubes
etcetera this is maybe one level of
abstraction away where instead of
looking at numbers individually we're
interested in collections and looking at
the properties that these collections
may satisfy let's start with a
definition so we'll say that a set s is
primitive if
no number in s is divisible or divides
any other so that's just saying that if
we have two numbers in our set that are
different say a and b that means the
ratio a over b and b over a are never a
whole number so if four and two
are in the set the set is not primitive
right right because four is a multiple
of two or two divides four i'm imagining
there are a lot of primitives i'm
imagining they're an infinite number of
primitives yeah i mean this is so so one
of the things we like about prime
numbers is that the definition is very
basic and kind of
so the primes are like the basic
building blocks of arithmetic because
you can build all the numbers kind of in
a unique way out of the primes and
similarly if you're now instead of
looking at individual numbers and you're
looking at sets of numbers a primitive
set so this definition is almost the
simplest you can kind of come up with in
the same spirit all the prime numbers is
an example of a primitive set yeah right
exactly so
is that the only set that has an
infinite number of members oh no that's
a good question so let's look at some
examples so let's consider the set of
numbers 4
6
9
10
15
etc so these are going to be the numbers
with two prime factors and here two and
only two yeah exactly two with so for
example with four we have a two and a
two so if the same prime occurs twice we
still count it as being in the set so
you know you have 2 times 2 2 times 3 3
times 3 2 times 5 3 times 5 etc and so
this is an infinite set of numbers and
i'm claiming that no number will divide
any other take the number 10 right so 10
is 2 times 5. the divisors of 10 are
therefore 1
2
5 and itself so we'll ignore the number
itself but we see the kind of list of
all divisors of 10 are not falling in
any of this list so this will have you
know no prime factors one prime factor
one prime factor and more generally if
you take any number uh let's say p times
q so any any number in this set is going
to be exactly the form p times q where p
and q are primes and
q might equal p but it may not but if we
play the same game the divisors of p
times q are 1 p q and then p times q
itself but we see in particular if you
have two numbers with two prime factors
you're never going to get one lying in
the list of the other yes so so in
general if a number has k prime factors
then
all its its divisors will have fewer
prime factors so fewer than k and all of
its multiples will have more than k
prime factors we've produced another
family so example two for any k the set
of numbers with k prime factors is
primitive so all the numbers with three
prime factors all the numbers with
exactly yeah why are they called
primitive because obviously they don't
have to be prime numbers primitive is
also kind of the idea of uh like a basic
building block um at the end of the day
these are just english words that have
been kind of chosen but this is meant to
convey some idea of these being
a very simple definition that's
containing some of the basic structure
we have these nice examples of just the
primes themselves we have numbers with
two prime factors three prime factors
four prime factors for any your favorite
k and these are kind of building some
intuition for what these primitive sets
are but in general the definition of a
primitive is very uh simple and so it
emits a very broad class of sets paul
erdosh was interested in these sets and
he proved the following result 1935
erdos showed that there is a constant c
such that for any primitive set let's
say s the sum of one over n log n for n
ranging in your set is at most this
constant c for any primitive set s what
does that mean this is saying that we
have a series that converges in other
words for any set you
throw at me i'll spit back at you a
number
particularly this conversion series
we've come up with a rule that assigns
every set a number the claim well like a
unique number yeah so this is this is
going to be a unique series so for
example with the primes we already knew
about the primes in particular we knew
that the series so this is
going to be 1 over p log p which
is nothing more than the sum of 1 over 2
log 2
plus 1 over 3 log 3
plus 1 over 5 log 5
plus 1 over 7 log 7.
so this is an infinite series one term
for every prime and the claim is that
this is finite so if you kind of ran
some uh computations on mathematical for
example this comes out to a number
that's about six three six six so you
telling me every set has like
almost like a fingerprint yeah exactly
so it's like a way to reduce the
complexity of a very uh jumbled uh
object and just come out spit out just a
simple number to yeah to kind of gauge
the the size of the set um can you
reverse engineer that too if i gave you
the c could you tell me what the set is
not necessarily so it's not it's not an
exact uh dna match by contrast the sum
of all numbers one over n log n over all
numbers or between one and infinity so
this is just okay so let's let's ignore
one because uh that'll get us problems
already but even just starting at two or
any finite place three log three so so
far we're starting off the same but now
we're going to include four plus five
log five but six electric etc this
actually diverges and goes to infinity
so air dish is telling us that for
primitive sets that we have this nice
sum that gives us information about the
size of the set but in general for most
sets uh this sum will diverge and then
kind of uh give us junk that we don't
know how to handle so we've got all
these these numbers that these constants
these numbers that can be attached to
various sets yeah so this is a way of
kind of assigning an index number to
every set and one should have the
intuition is that this is saying
something about the size of a set so the
erdos primitive set conjecture says that
in the theorem we can take c to be the
sum of primes so that is to say for any
primitive set this sum of 1 over n log n
for n
ranging in your set
is at most
this sum over primes 1 over p log p so
that's just 1 over 2 log 2 plus one over
three like three one over five log five
that one point six three yeah and it
comes out and this comes out to a finite
number
one point six three six six
so the conjecture is that every sum for
primitive uh over a primitive set is at
most about 1.6
okay and so there's no primitive set you
could create that would have one of
those fingerprint numbers yeah above one
point right exactly this is the upper
limit you can't do any better by being
as clever as you want this is this is as
good as it gets and so another way of
kind of thinking about this conjecture
and the reason why i particularly think
it's a very beautiful conjecture is that
even though primitive sets are
very so the definition of primitive set
is very simple so there could be all
these chaotic sets satisfying the simple
condition
and nevertheless there's this nice
condition saying in some sense
that
this kind of
measure of complexity is being maximized
by the primes in other words that the
primes are the largest primitive set
among all primitive sets as measured by
this uh uh nice statistic that kind of
like i can feel why intuitively that
would be true it would like it would
feel right that all the primes is the
king of primitives yeah so so that's i
mean uh for those kind of who who love
the channel i mean in our hearts we we
all feel that the primes are special and
um
it's hard it's sometimes hard to
articulate why uh we we love something
but
at least in this conjecture erdesh is
giving us one particular way of
articulating uh in a quantitative
rigorous way why the primes are special
at least in kind of
the broader context of its family of
larger sets so to go back to this
analogy uh we are saying that kind of
the primitive sets are the diamonds uh
that are kind of the you know if you go
if you go to a jeweler and get them
appraised the diamonds will always fetch
the the most some as compared to the
emeralds of the rubies and the sapphires
they're also going to perhaps be very
valuable but this is giving us some
consolation in our hearts that these are
really the the most brilliant jewels
that analogy falls down because rubies
are often worth more than diamonds but
oh okay
that tells you that tells you how much i
know about uh jewelry
okay so i guess the reason it may not
have been the case is because you showed
me that non-prime numbers can be in
primitive sets right right so you can
imagine a world where you could have
built some pretty impressive primitive
sets but you'll never get one you'll
never get one as good yeah that's the
point and so uh this was a beautiful
conjecture that eris and others had
worked on in the 90s and there wasn't
really much progress so when i heard
this problem back my undergraduate i was
just absolutely fell in love with the
problem so because it's saying that
these primes are very special uh in a
precise way but i i never really
expected to uh th this is this question
is like one of those uh kind of dreams
you have in the back of your mind that
oh it wouldn't be great if uh something
like this were true and i just uh never
kind of uh really gave up on the problem
this was your famar's last theorem was
it uh
you could say that uh i just i just
found this uh such a beautiful
uh statement what did you do what did
you see what did you think of that no
one else had thought of uh okay so the
first thing to say is that this is now a
theorem so uh so this is in 2022
uh
the
erdos primitive
set conjecture don't you get your name
on it now
uh
i guess if if you
shouldn't be the lichtman
uh primitive
if you say so
i don't know i feel that uh
it's it's not necessarily my place to
call that but if if you want to say i
won't uh
i won't uh uh argue with that what's the
key i mean i'm imagining it might be a
bit more advanced than i can understand
but yeah so it really goes back to ideas
of erdos back in the 1930s so he had
proved that for any primitive set you
throw at me i'll spit back a sum that'll
converge and the ideas that erdos really
developed back in the 1930s turned out
to be quite relevant to proving the full
conjecture i should say that the later
work that eddis did was in a very
different direction so it was not at all
clear that this these ideas were
relevant but essentially uh what i was
doing was essentially looking at
the the proposal that erdogan a
beautiful argument that kind of
reinterpreted what this uh series is in
a more uh probabilistic way and kind of
gave some more probability
interpretation for for these sets to
really give the idea that this series is
measuring the size there are a few key
ingredients in this argument that are a
little bit inefficient and by
identifying these steps and kind of
tuning them up and tightening the screws
and putting some oil
it turns out that erish's ideas could
really be continued a lot further than
initially thought so in your proof did
you sort of think
gosh erdog you were so close to doing it
yourself did he did he did not quite see
it yeah i mean i i also had been
thinking about other ideas uh that he
had gone off and done so i i really came
to this uh his original argument much
later and uh it was a
quite surprising to me that these sort
of ideas uh could be relevant um but
it was it was a really uh a really
beautiful moment where's where has your
proof been published yet or what happens
now the first step in letting other your
your friends and other mathematicians
know is you upload uh your proof to the
archive and then there's a more formal
process of getting it kind of submitted
to a journal and getting it reviewed
meticulously but i had also kind of
shared my proof with my advisor and
other article to kind of make sure that
i wasn't thinking wrongheadedly about
some things what did your advisor say
when you when you sent it through so uh
he actually didn't know i was working on
this problem so uh i
kind of half was thinking that he'd be
angry at me for not working on the
problem that he'd set for me and this
was like something i'd been dying by
candlelight at night surreptitiously but
so i'd let him know back in uh this
winter that i'd solved the or i'd come
up with this proof and he uh so he he
took time over several months to look at
it and kind of vet all the steps there
you know dot all the eyes and uh cross
all the teas uh but he he was uh also
very uh
happy for me and i was it was it was
just a very nice moment
a natural question to ask is so if
you're interested in primitive sets but
you're throwing away the primes now
suppose your all the numbers in your set
will be composite
then you can ask a similar question
so we know that there's still some upper
bound
but if we're looking at fewer sets then
these uh series could be even smaller so
the question is uh if you're looking at
primitive sets of composite numbers what
is the largest the sum can be
do you
do you have a
i'm going to guess
that number over 2
no
i don't know
yeah half that number or is it is it
vanishingly close to that number uh
that's actually a good question and uh
that relates to some of the ideas that
i'd been thinking about uh in the course
of the proof well has that number got a
name that like that upper bound
is it so this is just uh one of these uh
so so they're not the lichtman constant
i i i won't argue with you there so it
hasn't got a name yeah so this
particular sum over primes uh so there
are many uh sums you know uh for example
uh there's a famous sum one over p
squared uh which uh
may be familiar to some uh fans of the
channel um this also converges converges
actually quite a bit faster than the
series but yeah so it turns out that
this sum converges but just barely the
the conjecture is that if you're looking
at all primitive sets the primes are
maximizing but if you throw out the
primes the numbers with two prime
factors
is conjecturally the largest within this
restricted family of composite numbers
and more generally so this is also
one example of a much broader conjecture
which says if you're looking at numbers
with at least k prime factors for any k
that are primitive
this should be maximized by the set of
numbers with exactly k prime factors the
one with two prime factors that you tell
me is the next biggest yeah after this
this is an open problem oh we don't know
that we don't know this is the
conjecture this is a conjecture that's
been put forward what does that what is
the fingerprint number for the uh the
two prime factors if you look at so this
is uh i'm calling it the fingerprint
number yeah the fingerprint number
f for fingerprint usually we denote by p
as the set of primes and if you just
look at the set let's say p to the two
power this will be the set of number of
two prime factors so this is a sum this
will be one over four log four plus one
over six log six etc and you can kind of
play this game where you increase the
exponent and these numbers get smaller
and smaller one of the aspects of this
conjecture is that you'd want uh
every step that you increase k you'd
want this
corresponding fingerprint number to go
down and so you'd have this kind of
chain of inequalities saying that
the primes are the largest the numbers
two prime factors are the second largest
numbers of three prime factors and so
this is in some sense going back to your
comment earlier about trying to uh
recover some structure within this very
chaotic class of primitive sets um and
just kind of carve out some nice
decomposition in some kind of
prime way that we've seen before
so if i had all of the numbers with two
prime factors in a set
is it impossible i could throw one extra
number into that bowl or would that
break that would break the sets yeah
primitiveness would it yeah yeah so so
so because because then i could add my
fingerprint number if i could right
exactly so so let's let's take your
example so if we have we're starting
with the numbers with just two prime
factors and you want to throw in a num
another number so that number is either
going to be one which will divide all
numbers it'll be either a prime which
will divide
or it'll have at least three prime
factors
but
so let's say this number is p times q
times r
you throw away any prime
of these and then you'll have a number
of two prime factors but that's already
in our list
so the set of numbers with two prime
factors can't be increased anymore while
still being primitive so this is
sometimes known as a maximum maximal
primitive set
so
you can't increase it anymore
artificially more generally and for any
k the set of numbers with exactly k
prime factors
is going to be maximal in the way that
you can't increase the set anymore and
you can just see this by trying to uh
throw a number that either has fewer
than k prime factors and so in
particular divide a number on our list
or it will have more than k prime
factors and it will be a multiple of a
number in our list
so that that that really shows that
these are maximal but so in particular
for this conjecture i've lied to a
little bit brady so
it turns out these numbers with exactly
k-point factors are a very uh special
class of primitive sets and the set of
all perimeter sets is much larger so
this is this is the hope that you can
have this kind of nice way of saying
something about a very large class but
it turns out if you uh plug these uh
numbers in for for larger k it turns out
that after uh k goes past six the
numbers start increasing again
so the fingerprint numbers the
fingerprint numbers start to go down
from one two three four five six and
then at six they seem to go up again but
it's actually also a theorem due to
myself that these numbers tend to one as
k goes to infinity so they're really
wedged in this thin strip there may be
some other kind of super exotic set with
uh
of composite numbers that
conjecturally could pass
this threshold but we believe that this
is the best case so what i just
described with k equal six being the
minimum is actually breaking the
original conjecture of banks and martin
but there's a way of slightly tweaking
their conjecture by getting rid of even
numbers that can conjecturally recover
uh this nice picture so if you're
looking at
primitive sets of odd numbers then
there is still a glimmer of hope that we
can get a nice decomposition into odd
primitive sets
this way
these numbers so by introducing this
kind of seemingly abstract definition
his work introduced this definition and
really opened up this field and today we
know
kind of the statistic